after France was defeated in the second
world war the Armistice dictated that
the north of it was to be garrisoned by
German soldiers whereas The South was
allowed to remain unoccupied this part
of France is known as Vichy France due
to it being run from said town and it
was a German puppet state in orbit name
but despite its leaders acting in German
interests Vichy France never joined the
axis to fight the Allies in a more
formal sense so why not why didn't Vichy
France join the axis so as of the fall
of France president Albert Le Brun gave
absolute power to his recently appointed
prime minister Philippe patom and this
was to allow him to write a new
constitution baton dissolved the French
Parliament and made himself head of
state legally baton's government had
control over all of France in reality
though its Authority stretched only
throughout the non-occupied Zone his
government had to relocate from Paris to
Vichy here because it had the best
postal and telephone facilities outside
of the capital aspartum was attempting
to write a new French Constitution after
its defeat Britain was worried France
had withdrawn from both the war and the
allies and now sat as a neutral if
occupied State the British were
concerned learned that the French Fleet
would fall into German hands and so they
demanded custody of it for themselves
the French said no and so the British
calmly dropped the subject and some
bombs on the French Fleet the French
responded by bombing Gibraltar and it
would seem then that the two were at War
but France never made any declarations
nor did it try to join the axis and
there were several important reasons why
the first was that patan didn't believe
that France was ready to join the
conflict on either side the second
reason was that bhattan enjoyed
International recognition as the
legitimate ruler of France with some
exceptions and joining the war would see
this revoked by some it also meant that
the French people in both France itself
and the colonies wouldn't have to pick
aside since many weren't too happy about
the German occupation but there was also
a very strong anti-british sentiment
amongst the French people and Baton
didn't want to test which of these were
stronger the third reason was that the
axis didn't really want France to join
the German government didn't feel that
France would fare too well in an all-out
war and importantly they didn't want to
risk having to divert troops to help in
Africa it wasn't just Germany though
that didn't want France on the team the
Italian government had been eyeing up
French territory for a long time and
even a rump France on side could have
prevented Italy from realizing its
Ambitions and across the world Japan
wasn't a fan of France either its
ideological justification for its
conflict with the West Was freeing Asia
from European colonialism and France
held these lands that Japan wanted that
said the debate didn't last too long
since in late 1942 fearing that Vichy
France would either join the Allies or
fall to them the German and Italian
militaries invaded and put an end to its
existence thereby ending the short and
technically neutral existence of Vichy
France I hope you enjoyed this episode
with a special thanks to my patrons
James bizonette Kelly moneymaker call
show wolf Sky Chappelle kartoitska Jerry
lamdin Alex Schwinn Adam Stalter Jordan
Longley rod D Martin why in hockey
Marcus arsner Captain psydog Marvin
Castle Spencer Lightfoot Winston caywood
boogly Wiggly Daniel tobian kamoon Yoon
Miss izet Gustav Swan Aaron the white
Anthony Beckett the mcwoper Maggie
pascowski Coppertone spinning three
plates shewenin words about books
podcast and Charles the first